I don't think I'm the best I don't think
I'm the hardest working I think we're
pretty good I shouldn't say we're the
best I grow frustrated with people
counting the wrong things to the masses
about what matters absolutely you need
to do the work you need to put volume in
it's the only way you get better but if
you start claiming that you are the best
you cannot be at work you are making
statements that you know are not true if
we can shift the Mantra around this and
then refocus it on the things that
matter which are we have to get
sufficient domain expertise to get over
a certain level then we have to be able
to bring people on the team that can
help us out and then we work our way up
the coaching ladder once we're off the
field because you're no longer an
individual contributor and you work your
way up until eventually your head coach
or if you're smart you might have enough
money that you own the team and then you
hire head coach apple is owned by
shareholders the shareholders hire a
board to oversee the head coach head
coach of CEO same thing